South Park is still just as vital and
relevant as it was when it premiered in
1997 creators Trey Parker and Matt Stone
have since become a comedy brand unto
themselves with movies like 2004's Team
America world police and the hit
Broadway musical The Book of Mormon
let's take a look at the little cartoon
that started it all and discover the
untold truth of South Park viral VHS
when Parker and Stone were film students
in 1992 they used construction paper at
an old eight millimeter camera to create
a crude animated short called the spirit
of Christmas featuring a group of
foul-mouthed Colorado kids it was a
massive hit at campus screenings dude I
told you not to put that fat on frothy
bed
Corcoran stone didn't think about it
much until they moved to Los Angeles in
1993 and their indie movie cannibal The
Musical caught the attention of Fox
executives Brian Graydon he loved the
spirit of Christmas so much that he made
a hundred VHS copies and sent them as
holiday cards two years later
Grayden gave the pair two thousand
dollars to make another and they
delivered Jesus versus Santa which he
sent to 40 people and was widely
bootlegged around town I began to think
I was going to take off when I went to
parties and people kept trying to put it
in and show me my own Christmas card
unaware that it was actually my
Christmas card
George Clooney reportedly distributed
300 copies to his friends and within a
year multiple TV networks asked Parker
and stone to pitch a show based on real
people Parker and stone drew inspiration
from their own lives to create many of
the citizens of South Park
Cartman's promiscuous mom Lee Anne is
named after Parker's ex-fiance butters
is based on the duo's childhood friend
at South Park animation director Eric's
Tao and Cartman is named after their
high school friend NAT Cartman even mr.
Hankey the Christmas poo comes from
Parker's childhood when he'd forgot to
flush the toilet his dad would warn him
that mr. Hankey would crawl out from the
toilet and eat him fast turnaround most
animated series can take up to a year to
produce a single episode but an average
South Park episode has production
schedule of just six days that means the
show can comment on breaking news almost
as fast as live-action shows but the
process can be grueling
Parker and stone lead a team that writes
records and animates using a program
called Maya
often turning in completed episodes the
same day they're scheduled to air and
unlike many other long-running shows
South Park's creators remain extremely
involved in the day-to-day operations
they've only missed a deadline once in
2013 when their studios lost power
teamwork most episodes credit only Trey
Parker and Matt Stone as writers but
South Park employs a large staff of
writers and consultants lots of famous
names have popped into the writers room
including SNL's bill here who's also
voiced a few characters in certain
episodes Kristen Schaal wrote for a
dozen episodes in 2007 and sitcom legend
Norman Lear creator of all in the family
and good times even dropped by at age 81
Lear served as a creative consultant on
the episode with a boys learner earth is
just the set of a reality show created
by aliens so the man who created Archie
Bunker also brought us the ice cream
pooping taco fish dicks one of the
things South Park does best is tear down
celebrities while most celebrities the
show is steward of taking it to stride
Kanye West unsurprisingly did not all
right that doesn't I'm gonna kick him
out of ah in an infamous episode Tanya
doesn't understand a joke about fish
dicks real-life Kanye was also pretty
upset and discs out Park in his 2010
song gorgeous citing his intentions to
well choke a South Park writer with a
fish stick
okay then poor Kenny
oh my god they killed Kenny you bastard
self parks concept of killing off Kenny
in every single episode only to have him
return for the next episode is funny and
innovative but not entirely original
Parker and stone got the idea from MTV's
90s sci-fi action cartoon Aeon Flux in
which the main character frequently dies
Park Curtain stone also drew inspiration
from one of their childhood friends also
named Kenny who skipped school so often
that rumor spread that he died my friend
Kenny who at the bus stop all that he
had the little orange coat and he would
always say we couldn't understand him
like we can't understand you you know
and but he was the poorest kid in the
neighborhood and that's why you know it
was always like that's why we're always
like ever he would always sort of
disappear like what happened to Kenny is
he dead the cartoon Kenny doesn't always
die in later seasons although he was
semi-permanently killed off for a while
in season five until parker decided to
bring him back
timmy confined to a wheelchair and
afflicted with an unspecified condition
and only allows him to say his own name
Comedy Central reportedly didn't want
Timmy on South Park 10a executives were
worried Parker and snow would make fun
of people with disabilities but the do
O'Connor that the other kids would treat
him as just one of the gang fans
immediately took to the character and
Parker claimed people began shouting Tim
had him on the street instead of the
usual many critics praised South Park
for including Timmy and later another
physically disabled character Jimmy for
raising awareness of issues facing the
handicapped disabled viewers voted Timmy
the greatest disabled TV character in
the 2008 radar people of the Year awards
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos at
the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know which episode of
South Park is your favorite
[Music]